one of the big misnomers about the why
is it's only about our work
it's not it's about who we are
[Music]
oh hi there didn't see you
when i originally learned my why it
literally changed my life
i stopped talking about what i did and
started talking about
what i believed
it was amazing how powerful this why
statement became as a filter
for even the kinds of people i wanted to
work with i never imagined being an
author nothing changed i was the same
idiot as i was before
the only thing that changed is i learned
how to start with why the whole point of
this
is to now live our lives with purpose on
purpose
and the journey is remarkable